[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka mr. marvel and
if you loved Avengers endgame 3000 then
we finally have some more heartbreaking
info on the film that makes Tony Stark's
sacrifice even more noble throughout
this video I'll be breaking down the
recent Robert Downey jr. interview with
the off-camera show and discussing how
Tony Stark purposely built his suit for
one reason alone there will be heavy
spoilers here so if donna snapped you
out of existence and you haven't had a
chance to watch Avengers end game yet
then I highly recommend that you turn
off now without the way I just want to
give a huge thank you for clicking this
video now sit back relax and let's get
into my breakdown of the truth behind
the mark 85 on earth okay so first
things first I just want to kind of play
the key parts of the interview to show
how Robert Downey jr. views Tony Stark's
sacrifice with Marvel lives oh yeah
it's a complete 180 it started off with
someone who's absolutely self-centered
has more money than they could ever
spend is spiritually dead and has no
idea that they're about to go through a
crucible that is going to put them in a
position to be of service to their
community boom then by the end of it the
last suit he has isn't even designed for
him to be able to survive using it the
first suit is all about will this get me
and my ego and my precious physical
frame out of this cave I'm in and into
the desert where maybe the cavalry can
come get me and bring me back to my
stupid life right right right the last
one is not designed to be able to do its
job and have you make it past it so
that's the great you know Joseph
Campbell mythology of like ultimately
you go from refusing the call of being a
serendipitous hero and by the end you're
willing to give the ultimate sacrifice
your life despite your family and your
groundedness and your desire to not want
to do that so that the community can
thrive but it would be really a pity if
I couldn't ingest that and
you know and and make adjustments moving
forward so that I don't regress to old
behaviors or right or you know or say
well where's my next where's my next
massive franchise yeah cuz that that is
a losing game right there yeah maybe
yeah not in your case it doesn't feel
right
so clearly this kind of confirms what a
lot of fans including myself was
speculating about the mark 85 armor and
not only how it was designed but also
what its true purpose was Tony Stark has
always been a person who doesn't really
fit the mold of what we typically define
as a hero before his big turn in the
first Ironman film he was self-centered
misogynistic and not really accepting of
the responsibilities that had thrust
upon him
there's even shades of this and avenges
endgame when the group go to visit him
as Lodge and he doesn't really want
anything to do with them or their time
travel plan Tony Stark though he lost
the battle with Thanos actually came out
better than most due to the events of
infinity war the love of his life was
still around he had a daughter and all
in all it seemed like things couldn't
have really gone better for him as due
to the circumstances this is why he
initially doesn't want to help his
friends though he realizes that he's the
only one who can that's what makes his
moves and avenges and game all the more
heartbreaking Tony didn't have to make
the sacrifice but he still did and
that's what makes him a true hero it's
clear that Robert Downey jr. and stark
himself also knew that Tony would be
going on a suicide mission which is the
exact reason why he built his own
version of the gauntlet out of nanotech
that worked with his suit
Tony clearly thought that at some point
if he had to wield the stones he must
even though it would kill him which is
why he built the mark 85 suit to be able
to house them in order for him to carry
out the snap that saved the universe now
there was two options that Tony could
have taken either not build a suit this
way or create it knowing that if it came
down to it he would have to sacrifice
himself down he even says in the
interview that the suit is not designed
to do its job and for him to make it
past it which highlights that Tony
simply built the entire mark 85 with one
real purpose in mind the true job of the
suit is to handle the power of the
stones but just long enough so that
Tony can perform the snap if needs be
this is why we see the Hulk struggling a
lot more with wielding them as opposed
to Iron Man who is only really
completely torn apart by them upon
completing the snap it's a really
heartbreaking reveal that shows that in
the end Tony Stark was the kind of guy
who would lay down on the wire and make
the ultimate sacrifice even though he
already had everything that he wanted
Tony was a man who had everything to
lose and still did it anyway which makes
him the true definition of a hero and
it's no wonder to see why the MCU is at
such a loss without him obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on this
reveal and if it makes you enjoy the
film even more comment below and let me
know and if you like this video then
please give it a thumbs up and make sure
you check out my full breakdown of the
alternate ending to Spider Man far from
home would you be linked at the end I go
over how the writers of the film
originally wanted to end the movie and
give my thoughts on it so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more I'll also leave a link
to the original interview with Robert
Downey jr. in the description below if
you want to watch more and see his
thoughts on it I also just want to let
you know that we're giving away a free
copy of Avengers and game on blu-ray to
one lucky winner and all you have to do
is like this video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on this video in the comment
section below
the winner will be chosen at random on
August the 10th and the blu-ray will be
shipped out from there to ever get
surprised it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]